nous sommes très très heureux
que Laurel Folk EI organise une
réunion très importante samedi dans
le sud de la France pour engager des
discussions sur notre avenir en Europe
et sur l'avenir de la France au sein de l'Europe.
La France est bien sûr l'un de nos très  les
États membres les plus importants et la
relation entre le PPE et notre
parti frère, un républicain libéral, est
extrêmement importante et ces
discussions doivent avoir lieu à travers
le continent et c'est formidable de voir le
leadership de Laurent pour les principaux
républicains du PPE et
moi-même, en tant que directeur de campagne, j'entretiens d'
excellentes relations avec notre
délégation républicaine au
Parlement européen. Ils sont engagés et travaillent
très dur pour le peuple français et
le peuple européen. Nous vous souhaitons donc à tous un
succès continu dans ce débat très important
pour l'Europe et pour la France.  nous voyons
qu'un chemin familier est populaire et ouvert à
remarquer. Je ne suis pas un moyen d'affaire
della repubblica sur la France pour vous laisser
piétiner le cours. Je m'appelle Alex, vous savez,
ouvrez-le à Lisa, d'accord, qu'en est-il s'ils
espèrent que le  pool de France
Mexique salutations chaleureuses à nos
collègues français du PPE les prochaines
élections européennes seront absolument cruciales
il est important que nous ayons une
famille politique forte au sein du centre
santé droits pour que l'Europe
reste une famille politique qui
comprend également que l'Europe doit  être
quelque chose de différent aujourd'hui de ce qu'il était il y a 70
ans, mais cela sera toujours
positif et constructif les extrémistes
détruisent que nous avons reconstruit et construit Je vous souhaite
bonne chance L'
Europe a besoin de dirigeants qui comprennent ce qu'est l'
Europe, nous avons besoin de dirigeants qui
ont une vision pour le  L'Europe, par exemple,
comment relever les défis économiques, comment
améliorer le marché unique, comment améliorer
les opportunités commerciales et comment
renforcer notre sécurité, c'est pourquoi j'ai
toujours été heureux de coopérer avec
les nouvelles républicaines parmi les problèmes de ma mère,
son mantra zone difficile au
dilemme d'Amalapuram, Garcia regarde  d'eux l'argent il
y a un problème faites BJ à la famille vous les
gens voyez si por moi président de la ville
vous voyez l'opportunité vous avez besoin de commander de
moi
pas d'opération reste reposez une souris ils ne
veulent même pas s'il a vu ils viennent vérifier pour
moi si  tu pourrais avoir une maîtresse aloha
président habituellement illa voca prédécédant
juliana voir le costume Yaroslava moi c'était
un bateau sur bonjour à tous les amis en
France surtout à notre présidente de parti
laura Voki je vous souhaite une bonne
réunion fructueuse sur l'Europe nous avons besoin d'un
français fort  pilier de la famille du CPP et, ensemble, en
tant que Parti populaire européen, nous pouvons vraiment
donner à l'Europe une bonne direction